all right let's start with a reminder uh
that we may need we may not need just a
reminder that the one group that seems
to continually garner the loyalty of
this
kind of like
neo-reactionary right i've continued to
struggle with how we should refer to
sort of like trumpists because they're
they're not conservative
they're not neocons
but they are reactionary and they're
smitten with dictators and brutal
regimes and the one real loyalty that
seems to be unbending and unchanging is
to authoritarians in a new interview on
real america's voice which is rapidly
becoming one of the most unhinged
reactionary fact-free media outlets out
there
donald trump was bemoaning
the poor treatment of
saudi arabia
by the united states one of the biggest
violators of human rights in the world
we've treated them poorly
says donald trump in this interview take
a listen to this oh yeah you you kind of
stayed with them through the khashoggi
thing you said hey it's horrible but
it's not going to jeopardize a 70-year
relationship we have now they meet with
russia now they're buying uh they're
they're selling them oil and they're
taking uh robles trying to get rid of
the petrol dollar
do you feel that they've the that ksa
has stabbed us in the back
so i think this i think they've been
treated very badly by our country
uh they don't want to see the iran
nuclear deal that's a catastrophe i
ended it we were very very good with
saudi arabia and all of them they were
buying
massive amounts of our military
equipment and everything else
this really is beyond the pale
um and understand that they're all in on
it there are even even the question from
the reporter already is framed to give a
very particular perspective the
khashoggi thing
the khachoji khashoggi thing
it it's horrible but you know our
relationship over oil and weapons at
least
they're all saying it like it is right i
mean okay yes
it was
international premeditated murder at the
direction of the saudi royal family in
cold blood
of a member of the media planned well in
advance people flown in with bone saws
okay yeah i mean the khashoggi thing but
oil
weapons come on guys and it's really
kind of emblematic of how they see this
and we shouldn't forget that it's you
know this is not i'm not drawing a
parallel
between the khashoggi thing which was
one guy getting killed and 911. these
are two different things but it's the
type of minimization
proportional minimization which would be
like referring to 911 as
we have lots of buildings in this
country they knock down two they knock
down two buildings but we've had this
relationship for decades the oil and the
arms and we want the cheap gas and by
the way it's not not working out keeping
it super cheap we have to accept
the political reality that trump and his
voting bloc
their main
you know they're like chameleons where i
guess we we don't hate gay people or
maybe we do or we're not too concerned
with trans people but now all of a
sudden we are and maybe we uh we we
don't want the government involved in
health care unless trump's going to give
us some even better version of obamacare
where the government will be more it's
all malleable like putty really crappy
putty i should say
but the one thing that doesn't change is
they're just smitten with the autocrats
any opportunity to defend or minimize
the ills committed by
autocrats and dictators and human rights
violators that they will do that has not
changed and when you think of all of
trump's different unchanging uh
loyalties
the only ones i can find are to the
autocrats
and to people who line trump's pockets
and of course remember that there are
saudis that own trump buildings floors
condos whatever different different
pieces of trump properties i believe the
45th floor of trump tower and the like
it's not even really america first it's
really trump first and america first
as ugly as is the history of america
first
it's almost a distraction where trump
says to his base america first they love
it and they don't realize that it's
actually trump first at the end of the
day so just another one of these
examples trump has abandoned his
supporters he'll abandon republicans as
soon as they say well i didn't like this
one thing trump did oh that's a rhino
he'll abandon all of them but he
continues to be smitten with the
autocrats and that doesn't seem to
change